l'intersaison n'a pas été facile pour le
tfc avec un effectif sérieusement
renouvelé et l'arrivée d'un nouvel
entraîneur en la personne de marco
simonet a rien d'étonnant si à trois
jours de la reprise du championnat
l'équipe au fait plutôt profil bas
notre équipe est la structure en général
est assez assez bas et donc c'est ce qu'
il faut éviter le plus possible d d d
entrer dans des duels physiques et donc
c'est pour ça que il faut passer par
part et je pars la technique par la
disponibilité par une équipe qu'elle
bouge et pour éviter cette cette
situation que ça peut nous pénaliser
dans ces championnats
quant aux objectifs pour la saison à
venir mis à part évidemment le maintien
en ligue 2 on reste assez vague et l'on
évoque plutôt le long terme
cette semaine pour nous c'est essayer
d'aider créer les bases construit
quelque chose d très important pour
l'année prochaine il faut le plus vite
possible se serrer les maintiennent et
progresser dans tous les domaines
on a beaucoup des jeunes donc on a
besoin de donner du temps de jeu à ce
jeu là parce que il a de la qualité mais
il n'a pas d'expérience
l'objectif pour moi il est bien
l'objectif du jeu qui doit être
l'objectif principal pour l'instant et
voilà on doit progresser rapidement
mettre en place ce qu'on fait on
travaille énormément donc il faut que ça
il faut le retranscrire sur le terrain
et je pense que
il y aura de bons résultats l'adversaire
est de taille pour la première journée
lundi soir l'extérieur à nancy
les lorrains ont fini cinquièmes la
dernière saison il reste deux sérieux
prétendants à la montée en ligue 1